I want to buy the books so many great
stories in here okay there's a great
story you of course in the movie a few
good men with Tom Cruise yes Jack
Nicholson and in the book you describe
your onset you're shooting the movie
courtroom scene your mom is there and
your mom wants to meet Jack Nicholson
yeah and you're petrified yeah well
everyone's mom is crazy is that fair to
say yes yes it is
all right well mines nuts party of one
so she shows up we're shooting the
quorum scene Nicholson's on the stand
they have to put her over Nicholson's
other shoulders so that she won't be
seen on camera and she's chatting him up
I'm sitting at the table there across
from him the courtroom with Tom Cruise
do me more I'm like Where's Waldo in
this cast and I'm supposed to be looking
at Jack and all it sees my mom behind
him so I am freaking out you know and
Nicholson sees how unnerved I am and
things would be hilarious to give me a
hard time about it so he comes over the
table there where we're all sitting
between setups and says a kid I was in
hanging
listen it's wondering if you could do me
a favor it's open you might be able to
get your mom off my egg I wouldn't mind
so much but she's hitting on me
the hell am I supposed to do take your
mom back to my trailer he said what you
want
yeah yeah please don't play with my mom
got you also it's a complete side note
in your in your career you are a very
very very good poker player you entered
the World Series of Poker Main Event
yeah and you the big one and you got to
the highest level that any celebrity has
ever achieved yeah it was what did you
end up six thousand six hundred players
start the tournament on day one I went
out the end of day five one hundred and
thirty fourth which was crazy yeah to
last that long but I would torment the
guys at the table try to get inside
their heads with the impressions too
they let you do that well they didn't
want me to but this bit unnerved that
was up you're Peter Falk you're Columbo
do you ever do Pia Columbo to them yes
of course yeah the action will come
around to me and I would sort of act
like I didn't know what was going on I
wish it on me I'm sorry
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah well you do have a nice thing tell
us is this a Facebook app there's a
Facebook app called Hollywood Poker it's
one of these play for free apps onto
Facebook where people play poker but
this is a chance to play with
celebrities mm-hmm Hollywood Poker
there's a big charity tournament on the
22nd and I've got the Hollywood Poker
folks to donate a $1.00 first time for
your fans up to $100,000 to go to your
charity that is so it costs nothing
takes 30 seconds and it's again a chance
to hang out and also do something great
for charity
that's fantastic elaborate well we're
gonna work it out so that every single
dollar goes to a meal center in Lawrence
Massachusetts Coruna so that's gonna
feed people yeah I'm very excited about
this after of course Andy gets his cut
for no reason I gotta get it tastes
better he got a wet his beak